and then we can apply instead of Newton
plus dark matter because it's almost
relativistic we apply milgramian gravity
without dark matter and study the
structures which form and the
calculations which we've done show that
the uh what we observed so the
population of galaxies uh comes out just
right
[Music]
hello Krupa welcome to how the light
gets in hello
so in one of your many presentations on
cosmology you start by saying that no
physical Theory can never be proved to
be right is that because we can never
exclude the possibility of another
theory coming along
precisely some
yeah um so you you can look for example
at the Horizon so you stand on Earth as
I said the ocean of the Ocean looks flat
so you can bring up the hypothesis that
the Earth is flat and just from the
observation which are at uh which you
have available there is a viable
hypothesis which you can't disprove but
equally viable is the hypothesis that
the Earth is around and you just happen
to see a fat Horizon because that's what
happens when you step on a when you sit
on a on a ball and both hypothesis are
explained that particular observation of
a flat Horizon
but what about the claim that the Earth
is round isn't that a final kind of
precisely and so uh one needs to devise
we have two hypotheses and we can test
these now so the Flat Earth hypothesis
would tell you that if you go up in in
height
take a balloon or you go up on a higher
mountain or the to the top of a very
tall Mast of a ship and you will see
that the Horizon just extends and you
can calculate how it would extend if
it's completely flat right or the other
hypothesis is that when you go far away
you start seeing that the Earth is
actually uh curved and so you test both
hypothesis with that experiment and then
yes the Flat Earth hypothesis is
excluded falsified and you stop thinking
about the flat one stops thinking about
the fat Earth hypothesis and will only
consider the round earth hypothesis but
does that mean that it's proven to be
right once and for all
that's a very good question because we
can never prove a theory right so um uh
again so we see around earth now we've
discarded the Flat Earth and the
hypothesis now is it a perfect circle or
is it not a perfect circle but of course
all the remaining hypotheses which in in
we will continue thinking about
um of which they are still an infinite
number still have to always be
consistent uh with this Global
observation of the earth is around dish
right right it's of course not a perfect
circle or a perfect sphere right let's
move from uh sort of simple astronomy to
particle physics
and for particle physicists one of the
most exciting findings for them in the
last few decades was the discovery of
the Higgs boson a particle that was
predicted by the standard module in the
1960s but that was undetected until
um
2012 when scientists working in the
large hardened collider sort of detected
it however I've heard you say that
strictly speaking the claim that the
Higgs boson exists is a non-scientific
statement what do you mean by that well
the correct statement would be the
hypothesis that the Higgs boson does not
exist has been falsified with five Sigma
confidence
I see so it's it's just a matter of
being precise about the language with
which we describe science and separating
it from this kind of more colloquial
kind of language yeah so so with the
Higgs boson uh it's it's correct to say
today the Higgs person exists and we um
I don't want to use the word belief in
science right but in that case I'm
convinced the ex-person exists just like
I'm convinced that that the proton
exists or the electron exists which does
not exclude always the possibility that
they might be a completely different uh
mathematical construction which would
also contain entities which we call
protons but which have a totally
different theoretical description of
course we don't know whether this exists
maybe it exists we just don't know at
the moment and what about Dark Matter to
go from particle physics now to
cosmology it's an entity that's
postulated by cosmologists in order to
make sense of observations that would
otherwise conflict with general
relativity and some other theoretical
claims that cosmologists operate under
the so-called standard model of
cosmology so a lot of people are pretty
convinced that dark matter does in fact
exist are you skeptical of that
statement for the same reasons you are
for the Higgs boson statement of
existence or are there other reasons
that come into this yes no I'm um I
wouldn't say I'm skeptical I would I
would say that the existence of Dark
Matter uh cold Dark Matter particles has
been falsified with more than five Sigma
confidence
uh so um it's not there in fact it's
much more than five Sigma so
now
um which means can you tell us what five
sigmas for those who don't remember
their statistics yeah exactly yeah
that's so imagine you're You observe an
apple falling down from a tree right and
you could you see that for the first
time and you say that's interesting why
doesn't it fly up or go sideways right
so you do another observation and again
the upper falls down but you still you
wouldn't be you wouldn't at that point
say it's a law that it always falls down
because two observations don't really
make the decision right and um it's been
established that um you sort of if
you've completely lost confidence if you
have to do this uh two million times
that's the sort of um So You observe two
million um experiments of the falling of
Apple which detaches from the tree and
if in every single case it always falls
down following the same
um description of how it gets fast as it
falls at that point you you you would
say you have the five Sigma confidence
um which means that the probability that
the Apple will not fall down has become
negligibly small you just don't want to
entertain that idea anymore because it
will absolutely not be economic so going
back to dark matter what makes you
believe that darker matters existing has
been disproven with such high confidence
because we've done since 25 years we are
studying the properties of galaxies and
um we've put a lot of emphasis into
understanding how galaxies function so
we means myself and the collaborators I
have in many countries and um there are
a few key experiments you can do
experiments in the sense of
um uh the theory predict making us very
clear hard predictions the Dark Matter
Theory and then we can test that against
the observations and one particularly uh
strong uh prediction is uh that we if
you have galaxies orbiting other
galaxies and they are moving around in
the dark matter Halos every galaxy has
this huge Dark Matter hello and if it's
moving around the stock matter hello it
will be suffering it will be losing
kinetic energies it will be getting
slower and Falling Towards the center of
the other Galaxy and merge so this is
called the dynamic of friction it's the
same as if you have a pot of honey and
you put a marble into the honey it will
not accelerate downwards but it will
slowly sink although if you have the
same pot without honey the ball would
just fall down quickly in the hand it
will sink slowly so that basically the
same thing happens in a dark but the
hello a Galaxy enters the stock but how
long it slowly sinks down
it does an extra red fast as it should
if there were no Dark Matter hello so
we've tested this observationally and
the effect of the slowing down is not
there yeah with uh with that type of
confidence and um so galaxies are
encountering each other far too rapidly
and a case in point is the large
measuring clouds which is just not
racing past our milkway very close to
the Milky Way actually and it's far too
fast
so and the small management counts too
and so this was a prediction that was
made by the the claim that dark matter
exists and it's been falsified yeah
absolutely Obsession so why do people
still in your view cling on to this idea
of dark magic well that's an interesting
sociological problem which uh one would
like to understand because it has no
rational basis
it is non-rational and it's probably
related to
um to um
sociological pressures in the community
so when students come into the research
so they study that they want to do a
project research project they are
um for one thing attracted by their
interesting ideas and and possibilities
of doing research and the other by
um how great the group looks like they
would like to join so it's Tribal
thinking and um and that pulls a lot of
young people into an established
um
thinking because just that's where they
can have a career that's where the
funding is that's where the leaders of
the field are famous they get prizes and
that's a self-strengthening system in a
scientific establishment which relies on
competition for funding and that is
simply and I think that's the whole
fallacy of the situation that um
that comes from American United States
this concept of competition for funding
in The Sciences is the most stupid idea
you could have even thought up because
that's absolutely not how science Works
in order to um to discover the laws of
nature you cannot compete with anybody
you can only follow your intuition and
work on that for as long as it takes to
to develop an idea and maybe sometimes
some ideas simply don't get developed
into new theories or not successful
theories but that's just what you have
to do you cannot have scientists
competing for funding in order to
improve our understanding of nature
that's just the most stupid idea ever
put up in terms of our civilization you
can do that in economics you get a
better product and that will be bought
and then you invest into that but not in
science absolutely not science is Art
yeah
you you are you a scientist the
brilliant scientist paints a picture
which is the theory for that they
sometimes have to invent their own tools
like Newton had to invent the
mathematics to actually do the
unification hit which you did fully up
with the motion of the Moon and yeah and
that's upon us to to do today to allow
the scientists to work creative
creatively and the question is how does
how does one sell this concept that you
you allow some people to be supported by
the taxpayer
to um to do that
it looks like a holiday you know people
just dream of they go on a ship for
three years and just dream up some ideas
funded by the taxpayer right doesn't say
it sounds right on the other hand
um that's actually the basis of how our
civilization progressed uh in every
single case people always invented the
new Concepts not under pressure but
because they themselves wanted to
understand what's happening out there
that's so let's get back to the kind of
scientific motivation for Dark Matter
putting aside all these interesting kind
of claims about the sociology behind it
dark matter was originally postulated to
explain some observations that didn't
seem to make sense with the theory of
gravity that we had what's the
alternative do we need to abandon our
theory of gravity do those observations
mean that that's wrong well given the
scientific deduction the dark matter
does not exist with more than five Sigma
confidence one cannot consider that
model further and so we have to indeed
consider how can we explain what we
observe out there and so the next thing
we do is to look at another proposition
which was formulated by Milgram in 1983.
it's a it's a different law of
gravitation people call it the modified
Newtonian Dynamics
um nature doesn't modify anything so I
would I prefer to just call it
milgramian gravitational logarian
Dynamics in equivalence with Newtonian
gravitation and and that's what we're
doing so we are working now to develop a
new cosmological model with the basis of
those equations of motion because
um just like Newtonian gravitation we
get equations we can put into type into
the computer the differential equations
which the particles have to follow and
solve so we can do that in more we can
do that in Newton that is falsified and
so we are testing those calc those
models under various
boundary conditions one boundary
condition is there's a hot big bang
CMB is the Photosphere of the hot big
bang and then structures evolve as
Universe expands in a in a traditional
Manner and then we can apply instead of
Newton plus dark matter because it's
almost relativistic we apply milgramian
gravity without dark matter and study
the structures which form and the
calculations which we've done
um show that the what we observed so the
population of galaxies comes out just
right yeah you get these disc galaxies
with a proper correct properties you get
the correct number of galaxies as a
function of mass and the correct density
of galaxies around us so that's most
most most remarkable and exciting and um
and so we now will continue this by
looking at whether we need to relax
um whether there are some tensions with
this picture this needs larger scale
calculations
was there Big Bang
and so on so is it this theory is called
the modified Newtonian Dynamics does
that mean that we're going a sort of
step back from Einstein and Einstein's
theory of general relativity as an
alternative to Newton's theory of
gravity and just modifying instead of
making the leap from the Newtonian
Paradigm to Einstein we're just
modifying Newton what's what's the right
way to think about it
the way I think about it is that the
correct one I don't know but um
uh it's not a modification well
technically the way it's done is it's a
it is mathematically one starts with a
Newtonian gravitation uh and modifies in
the sense of of of putting into the
equations that the accelerations change
when the curvature of uh so the gradient
of the potential so the curvature of
space becomes
um nearly negligible yeah and and
um and that can be put into
um a body on body fiber generalized
poisson equation and the way I think
about it is that Einstein gravitation so
Einstein postulated that we understand
gravitation as a consequence of
curvature of space and time but that's
just one possibility there are other
possibilities uh gravitation could be an
emerging phenomenon from
the different regions of space having
different information content that's
from valinda all because particles are
waves and so they react to changes of
refractive index which they themselves
change because the oscillations in some
medium we call it the ether if you like
and um so the thing is that gravitation
is the least well understood
a phenomenon I wouldn't want to call it
a force because it might not be it
doesn't seem to be a force
um since the least understood phenomenon
so it's not surprising that the one
formulation which is currently
um favored the einsteinian formulation
fails and that's just not no surprise it
could have worked well it doesn't so we
need to go on from that
Milgram gave us a non-relativistic
formulation which seems to work
incredibly well every every single
prediction made in 1983 about objects
which at that time had not been known
they had astronomers didn't know about
those type of objects and they've all
been verified it's most it's one of the
greatest success stories in science
actually
and um and so that's an indication that
the true understanding of gravitation
whether it's verilinda or particle wave
nature
um will need to allow and compass that
formulation by by Milgram
so we're often told that we have really
good indications that general relativity
is a better account of gravity because
things like GPS that we rely on rely on
general relativity and the way in which
it relativizes time in some way in which
it sort of time there's time dilation
depending on the gravitational field and
so on so does modified Newtonian
Dynamics able to account for these
discrepancies in time when it comes to
different gravitational fields yes so um
when uh formulating a new theory of
gravitation one of course always must
make sure that this new formulation
accounts for the phenomena which have
already been established and that's what
Einstein did too Einstein when he
reformulated the gravitation in terms of
space-time curvature so geometric in
interpretation there's a long section in
his 1916 paper where he discusses how
this new formulation becomes identical
to Neutron's formulation because at that
time it was one really known and well
established that new transformulation
works very well in the solar system and
that's what Einstein was working with
Einstein was only working in the solar
system because galaxies had not been
discovered right
uh and so with uh Milgram and
gravitations except exactly the same one
make sure that the well-established
regime which is the Newtonian
gravitational regime works just as it
does
that also includes uh then by
implication Einstein in the description
within strong gravitational fields
including our solar system and that the
departure in the regime with space
tanker which is extremely small or
negligible
so basically binkowsky space in their
additional phenomena start playing a
role and probably the quantum vacuum
affects the Motions of objects in that
regime and Milgram actually wrote a
paper on the 7099
laying out this possibility and so this
is a really exciting uh opening of of
doors towards possibly merging of
understanding of gravitation with
quantum mechanics and the um the
remarkable uh situation about this is
that the uh because the physical physics
community and the astrophysical
community has been entirely ignoring
this incredible opening of the doors on
a massive scale which again I must say I
do not comprehend how scientifically one
can ignore such great ideas and not and
that people didn't continue and develop
them in any further way
so I think we might be seeing a
departure from unsteining gravitation
because of quantum mechanics it's a
possibility
one of the claims that philosophers of
science have sometimes made is that
there is this thing called the
undetermination theory that theories
when when we have competing theories
that are trying to explain the same
phenomena data alone are not able to
sort of determine which of the two
theories is the correct one
because theories are always capable of
being adjusted in some ways having
additional postulates and so on
so do you think this is one of the
reasons why
the scientific immunity hasn't moved yet
to modify Newtonian Dynamics
and abandon general relativity because
the data alone don't tell us which of
the two is correct yes so I wouldn't go
as far as to say that we have to
Abundant General activity altogether
because I was just saying that maybe if
we just group on the mechanics on it in
that sense as Milgram suggested maybe
some
reasonable approximation to reality can
be achieved but
um
I think we are well beyond the situation
where we have two theories competing
um and um because of the falsification
right so the the because we want to
decide
which Theory will be more relevant and
is relevant for the theory for real
Universe because the real Universe
cannot be milgramian and have called
Dark Matter in it this would not work
and so I've we've devised this test of
Dark Matter Theory which is extremely
robust and does not allow any leeway in
the sense of saying we can adjust the
theory and that test is very simple we I
was saying I mentioned that before we
just measure the Motions of the Galaxy
so how much energy does the Dark Matter
hello absorb from the Motions of the
massive objects within it and uh and
that is simply not not evident in the
data and so one particular very nice
test which falsifies the Dark Matter
existence of cold dark matter or warm
dark matter with more than 10 Sigma
confidence I mean that's uh false you
couldn't imagine a more significant
falsification than that I mean the rule
is the existence of cold or warm dark
matter is totally massively falsified
right and and that's very simple so the
bars of galaxies have bars if you look
at a spiral galaxy it has the of many
that have a bar you see the pictures of
a disc and there's a big bar in the
middle right and and those bars of rigid
rotators they rotate around is the
Galaxy is rotating so we can measure how
fast they are rotating and this bar
contains a lot of mess so as it's
rotating it's like a spoon in a cup of
coffee
if you take a spoon and the coffee is
there and you you
um whirl around and the coffee starts to
rotate and and you have to exert
pressure on the on the spoon to keep it
rotating otherwise the spoon will just
uh stop rotating basically because the
the coffee rotates but you wouldn't spit
it up to this to the speed of the spoon
you let the spoon go and the spoon slows
down and so exactly the same thing
happens with the Dark Matter here we've
got the Galaxy the bar and the Dark
Matter hello and the bar is like the
spoon it's whirling around in the Stark
Mata hello and speak and and exerting
energy on it so that dark matter header
starts to move around to the bar but not
as fast and the bar slows and becomes
smaller yeah and this has been
calculated to death you can do this very
precise calculations the computer and we
do this effect is absolutely not in the
data the Galaxies have big bars and
they're rotating very fast too many
galaxies in fact most galaxies with bars
it's about half of all Galaxies have
these bars which are big and rotate and
this is physically impossible if there
is dark matter and that's why I'm so
completely confident there is no dark
matter
which means Dark Matter theory is not
um cannot be entertained anymore it's
just something a reasonable reasonable
physicist who really wants to do serious
research but not consider dark matter
anymore
can you tell us a little bit more about
what the response to that critique is
from the supporters of dark matter so
apart from sort of explaining the
phenomenon another microscopic scale by
saying like well
well economic interests involved in
denying this what are the actual
arguments what do people say when they
are confronted with this data well I
think the general argument would be to
say that galaxies are very complicated
and we can't do this exact calculations
uh but that's what they always do I mean
this com dark Better Community always
argues that the normal matter which we
have in the computers in terms of stars
and gas
is badly understood and that's why the
models don't match with the observed
galaxies
and that these not understood baryonic
processes or baryon means just normal
matter so gas and stars that is not
understood processes lead to these
disagreements
remarkably if we do well we we can do
these calculations meanwhile extremely
precisely so that actually generally
it's not not a correct statement that
that there are these uncertainties but
even if there were these uncertainties
and we would do this and we do these
calculations in a growing gravity so we
take the Galaxy with the bars and we set
up the Galaxy's in Belgium in fact we
let the galaxies form in Gravity from
from cosmological gas clouds we get the
galaxies as they are observed the bars
are as fast as observed the match with
the observational data
with the known physics of the normal
matter is stunningly good yeah so and
we've tested we've had very interesting
calculations and tests we've constructed
galaxies with with very poor
descriptions of these baryonic physics
and with extremely complicated
descriptions with radiation transfer
Supernova explosions
um chemicals so the transitions of of
electrons and atoms absorbing radiation
and um both of these uh calculations the
one is very expensive takes a lot of
time computes the other one is much much
simpler quicker both of them lead they
do not affect the results in any major
significant way or I mean one Galaxy is
maybe a little bit more larger than the
other Galaxy starting with the same
conditions but that is simply a level of
uh disagreement which is which is not
relevant and so if we do the
calculations we the uncertainties in the
baronic physics do not seem to affect
the results in dark matter they use that
as an argument to to to argue that the
theory is correct it's just that we have
two large uncertainties and I think that
is wrong but even independent of those
uncertainties the test of chandraseka
dynamical friction so the Slowdown of
the bars the Motions of satellite
galaxies are independent of these
uncertainties and there's no way of
saving the Dark Matter picture given
those data and can you tell us a little
bit about
um This Promise of
a more complete theory of gravity being
able to unify quantum mechanics with a
more complete theory of gravity and how
that promise might be found by by
following in the footsteps of this
milgramian model of gravity
well I think that's
um what I can only say to that is in the
end only speculation but then of course
speculation leads to uh the development
ideas which can then be put into
mathematical formulations
the speculation is that
um in um in the
um so that this is what Milgram
discussed in in his paper 1999 that um
in in a normal in a space like we have
here with with the space is quite curved
which is why apples fall down quite fast
because space series is curved and why
we sit on the chairs and so on
um so einsteining gravity applies and
Newtonian gravitation applies
and that's and that's uh uh comes from a
property of how partic individual
quantum mechanical particles accelerate
in this curved uh space time in the
sense of how the quantum vacuum is blue
shifted in front of the particle when
it's accelerated so the quantum vacuum
is a is a vacuum where particles and
anti-particles appear and then any light
again and this is constant bubbling so
it's content certain amount of energy
and when you accelerate through this
then the front is blue shifted exerts
more pressure against you than the back
and this leads to the uh um to the
result that you need forced to x-ray the
particle because you're sort of x-rating
it against this vacuum of uh energy and
in the situation where the um curvature
is negligible
the um this this larger symmetry between
the front and the back and um and that
cancels out and you get an effectively
larger acceleration
so this is one interesting idea
um can one understand this in terms of
quantum field Theory I do not know more
research much more research has to be
done on this there's an entirely
different possible interpretation and
that is that particles are just waves we
know that there are waves and particles
because you can describe a particle just
as a wave packet the wave packet to
business oscillation you you can
hypothesize the existence of a medium
Call It The Ether
we can we can discuss whether the ether
exists or not right that's a really
interesting question but say there is
this Ethan which light propagates and
particles exist as oscillations the
oscillations change the refractive index
just tiny little amount it's an
incredibly weak effects and then another
particle which is also a oscillation
which is made of all these waves which
are creating this interference which we
call the particle is then refracting on
the change of the effectiveness of the
one particle and that leads to a change
in the position of this uh wave just
naturally that you get that completely
nitrogen Optics it's just refraction of
waves and that leads to gravitation and
we are actually we have a project in in
Bon on exactly this question we've
already published two papers on this we
are now investing anything that's in
more details so you sense you set up
these waves and they actually do attract
each other and so you get gravitation
just from the fact that particles are
quantum mechanical structures because
there are these waves of course what do
they oscillate in what's the medium in
which these particles oscillator that's
a big question yeah you did mention the
term ether a few times I wanted to ask
you is this the same ether that Einstein
was sort of
um well Einstein sort of disproves
according to the standard account of
special relativity right we so we used
to think that there was an ether
electromagnetic waves traveled through
it it was a medium but then special
relativity seems to suggest that that's
that's not the case so is it the same
ether is this a different kind of well
so so mentioning that with ether of
course um in the eyes of my colleagues
would terminate my existence as a
physicist because today the ether is a
no-go right however Mickelson Morley in
um the 19th century in the Case Western
Reserve University United States made
this famous experiment because the Molly
experiment where they tested for the
existence of The Ether by looking where
the light rays are a blue or wretch of
the depending on how the Earth is going
around the Sun so the direction and they
did not find an effect from that the
conclusion is that The Ether does not
exist and yes Einstein postulated that
now um if we go back to this experiment
one because morally they assume that the
measuring devices were rigid and it's
only the waves the the photons which um
suffer the blue
um uh or ratchet or zopler shift and um
if however particles are themselves
waves then they also suffered exactly
the same Doppler shift which means you
measurement apparatus just like the
photon is is shifted is Doppler shifted
in exactly the same manner and all the
effects of The Ether cancel out you
cannot detect it in that particular way
and
um the uh Einstein interpretation of a
constant speed of light in the vacuum
which means he has one has to when you
have a strong gravitational field you
essentially get more space yeah this is
the interesting thing that if you take
the Earth if you take the region around
the Earth in a box and the Earth is not
there you can calculate the volume in
the box now you put the earth into this
exactly same box and you you end up
having more space in there that's
curvature of space right and um
that same effect as can be obtained by
saying that the speed of light changes
slightly because of the refractive index
which is actually changed by this uh
body of Earth and now that's an idea
which we are entertaining with a tiny
little project on the side just
investigating the implications maybe we
can throw it out of the window maybe we
can see that there will be some sort of
major fallacy but at the moment this has
not happened
well that would be a true kind of
revolution in some ways overthrowing the
Mickelson Morley experiment finding and
well that that we have already published
actually the the fact that the
experiment was
ill-device because
um they did not understand at that time
that particles are waves no they didn't
know that the source discovered much
later so obviously they wouldn't be able
to have handled that but today we know
that and so we can do this
reinterpretation it's a very fascinating
situation you know you can ask yourself
what's holding up the cosmological model
the Big Bang the CMB Cosmic microwave
background is always the argument by the
community to say we know the model is
correct because of the CMB the CMB and
we have great the theoretical we have
great deep theoretical understanding of
the CMB the power spectrum and so on
it's supposed to be the footprint from
them exactly yeah and um now um I had no
reason to adapt it of course but what
appeared fairly recently
um was a research paper by a somebody in
Prague actually who pointed out that
there is dust between galaxies
how did you get this interesting
question but it's measured from a
quasi-absorption runs so this dust
between galaxies is a very small amount
but there is another huge amount of
space right if you take all the stuff
between the galaxies you go backwards in
time the universe was smaller so the
dust density was higher The Starlight
was blue and because he had more younger
Stars the further go you go back you go
in time the dust was warmer and if you
now calculate how much photons the dust
because the dust absorbs light from the
stars in the surrounding galaxies reread
dates this in the infrared and then this
radiation is redshifted to come to us
today
if you do all of this calculation this
is what the colleague of average sugar
did and I did not know him before at all
I just noticed his paper
he showed that if you add up all the
photos from all this dust going back to
the Early times of the universe that
flux is that same amount we observe at
this as the CMB
so since I've seen his paper I'm asking
everybody I I know would be
knowledgeable to tell me where is the
error in his calculation because if
there's no error then we have the
nuclear bomb for cosmology
because then the evidence for the big
hot big bang disappears The only
evidence you would have is that the
universe is expanding which I think is
an established observation because of
the redshift
but the CMB interpretation would still
be cosmological it would just be dust
and not the actual Photosphere of the
universe completely changing the initial
condition for any cosmological
simulation you want to do so now we have
to understand this that beverage should
make an error in the calculation he
published published it in 2018 no error
has been discovered so far I've not
heard of anything and
um
you know this means that we are truly
looking at a one of the greatest
possible Paradigm changes in our
understanding of cosmology and all of
Sciences which is comparable to um to
the revolutions we we had with
Copernicus and Darwin I think
because
um maybe in 50 years time we will
understand the universe in a completely
radical manner which people can't even
most people can't even imagine today
thank you very much well thank you it
was a great pleasure
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV